Now, I'm not going to spend time on 1
Corinthians 15 today. Lord willing, in
the future, we'll unpack it because he
talks about how everything has a body.
And among the earthly creatures,
creatures made from the dust and the
follow, they all have certain kind of
flesh bodies. See, all flesh is not the
same flesh.
And all heavenly bodies are not the same
bodies. The sun is different from the
moon. Star difference from staring.
Okay, you get it. Anyway, nonetheless,
this is the context.
But one thing I want you to see from
this. All right.
So, let me know you're ready to learn.
Class has begun. One thing I want you to
learn from this
is what
this implies when it says death is also
an enemy that will be destroyed.
Can you with me there?
Death is also an enemy that will be
destroyed and it's the last enemy to
destroy. You know what that means,
brethren?
God did not create
animals.
Follow the air, humans, marine life to
die.
And you know where you find this
explicitly stated in the wisdom of
Solomon chapter 1 12-6. That's why you
need the duo canonicals
in your Bible. In fact, all Protestant
Bibles, this historical fact, every
Protestant Bible, even Martin Luther's
Protestant German Bible, had the duo
chronicles, which they called the
Apocrypha, the seven books that are
found in Catholic Bibles up until the
1820s.
And the original King James, included
the Deuteronomicals.
They were only removed in the 1880s
because they knew these books had to be
read because historically
throughout the centuries many Christians
accept the scripture and in our councils
when defining the canon they're included
as part of the canon right so they knew
they had to study these books and cannot
just get rid of them wholesale
okay and the best YouTube channel on
this topic that gives gives you
historical facts and data and refutes
the best objections by the Protestants
against the duter chronicles. Gary
Machuda's apocrypha apocalypse. Okay,
so you need the duter chronicles. Let me
show you what it says. Did God create
animals,
marine life,
humans to die? No. That means if you're
going to be faithful to the Bible and
you're going to be faithful to scripture
and if you're going to be faithful to
the historic interpretation
understanding of the church until the
rise of the enlightenment and evolution,
you cannot hold to the earth being very
old
because there was no animal death, no
human death, no death that occurred
among the animals, the birds, marine
life
up until
Adam and Eve sinned.
And I've done sessions on this. Go watch
the sessions. Animals and humans up
until the flood did not eat flesh.
Animals did not eat animals. Animals did
not eat humans. Humans did not eat
animals. They all ate fruits,
vegetables, and plants.
It's only after the flood, after the
flood that God allowed humans to now eat
flesh without blood in it and put the
fear and dread of man upon the animals.
So that animals now instead of living at
peace with men became afraid and would
attack men and would pray on one
another. Okay.
So you cannot hold to an old earth if
you believe there was animal death
already occurring
billions of years before humans showed
up. That means the Bible's wrong. All
right,
you ready now?
Wisdom of Solomon. If you believe the
Bible, this is your position.
If
if you believe in the Bible, this is
your position. Okay. So, let me make it
let me get this out of the way. Wisdom
of Solomon chapter 112:16. Do not invite
death by the error of your life, your
life. So, death
is a result of sin, nor bring on
destruction by the works of your hands.
Because God did not make death. Can it
be any clear? You see that right here?
God did not make death.
God did not make death
and he does not delight in death and
living. He didn't say just humans.
God did not create for your dog to die.
God did not create for your cat to die.
Do you know that? Why do you think even
animals fear death, run from death, and
when they know they're dying, they get
sad and lonely and cry?
Where do you think that's from?
One second, guys. Let me just get my
coffee. Where do you got Where do you
think that's from, guys?
God did not make death. He does not
delight in the death of the living, not
just humans. For he created all things
that they may exist. Do you see it? He
created all things that they may ex
exist. Do you see that?
He didn't create animals to die. That's
why dogs, cats, animals,
when they sense death, they flee. They
fear death and avoid it. Where do you
think that came from? And when they're
sick and dying, they realize they're
dying. They get sad and cry. Where do
you think that came from?
God created them to live
and all the generative forces of the
world are wholesome. God did not create
the create the world with any
destructive elements, poisons or toxins.
That's all the result of sin and the
judgment for sin. There is no
destructive poison in them. And the
dominion of Hades is not on earth. God
did not create
death on earth so that Hades would reign
on earth because Hades is the realm of
the dead. For righteousness is immortal.
See it? Not just death upon humans. Are
you getting this?
You listening? God did not create
anything to die. There were no toxins or
poisons. He created things to live, not
just humans. So you can't have billions
of years of history and animals dying
before human sin.
The dominion of Hades is not on earth
for righteous and mortal. But ungodly
men by their words and deeds summoned
death and consider him a friend. They
pined away and they made a covenant with
him because they are fit to belong to
his party.
And then what does it say here in wisdom
22 23- 24? But we're going to read 22-
24. Watch here. Wisdom 22 23- 24. Let's
read 22. And they did not know the
secret purposes of God, nor hope for the
wages of holiness, nor discern the price
of blameless souls. For God created man
for incorruption. He didn't create you
to die and made him in the image of his
own eternity. So what does it mean to be
in the image of God? To be immortal like
God. So then why do we die? Through the
devil's envy, death entered the world.
And those who belong to his party
experience it.
Okay?
So you see death is unnatural. Death is
an enemy. God did not make death. He
didn't want anything to die. That's why
1 Corinthians 15:26 called death an
enemy. God hates death and will destroy
death. You with me there?